では よろしくお願いします
えっと あの先月 このお寺に来ると
なんか看板にあの自信過剰のタイトルがありまして
私はあの閻魔様の話を準備して来ていたんだから
なんか随分自信がなくなって
なんかどうなっているのかと
だから まあそういうことで
ちょっとしたことで自信っていうのがなくなるんです
でまあ今日は一応自信過剰の危機ということで
で あなたは自分を信じる
あるいは自分を疑うということで
まあ自信というあのことっていうのは
大体私たちにとってはとてもとても大事なテーマだとは思います
あまりこういう自信過剰になって
あまり可愛いと抱きしめちゃう
大変なことになるということに
自信過剰と言えるところか
ということで まあ我々も自信過剰というテーマについて話す前にやらなくちゃいけないことがありますよ
そもそも自信があるのかという疑問なんですよ
自信過剰の話をするところじゃないんで
本当は大勢の人々っていうのは
そんな大した自信がないんですね
だから そこは一番大事なところだと思いますよ
自信過剰な人っていうのはそんなにたくさんいるわけじゃないんです
自信があるのかという疑問がありました
社会では自信がない人の方が多いんですね
あまり説明しなくなっても
もうよくわかっていることだから
どんどん飛ばしちゃいます
一番大きな問題は自信がないことだと思います
それは私は勝手に思いますけど
皆様はどうかわかりません
そういうことで まずそこから考えてみます
自信がないということはどういうものかと
自信がないと体が動かないというテーマにします
あの 大体自信がないということは行動できないという意味なんですね
何もすることができないという意味なんですね
だから自信がなくなると
人間っていうのは体が動かないというふうに単純に理解した方がよろしいと思います
何かをしたいとしても
大変苦しい 自信がない場合は何かしたいんだけど
頑張ってやってもものすごい苦しいんですよ
では 自信がない場合は
人を活発に動けないようにする何かの抵抗
抵抗力があるのではないでしょうかと
だから自信がないということは
我々の活発性というか
活発に元気で明るく生きていられない
行動できない 何か抵抗力が入ってるんですね
何か邪魔者が入ってるんですよ
人間の活発さをなくす
この抵抗力 今 最近ずっと何年ももう流行ってる言葉だからね
は何でしょうかと  抵抗勢力ですか
抵抗勢力です この抵抗力っていうのは何でしょうかと
でも何でしょうかという前に
一応その抵抗力はあることは確かなんですよ
何か抵抗力が抵抗が働いちゃって体が動かない
これは他人のせいにすれば楽なんですね
私のせいじゃないんだと
他人のせいっていうのは
大体世の中でよく一般的に言ってることは
もう神様とかね あるいはもうその怨念とかね
あるいは親の親の教えとかね
そういう人々の躾 しつけが悪く
躾が悪かったとかね そういうふうに何か言い訳を言うと
これは他人のせいなんですね
あるいは会社のせい 社会のせいだとかね
あるいは自分 遺伝的にそうなってるんだとかね
これは全部この何のかのせいにすれば気分が楽になると思います
まあしょうがないと これはもう戦争の怨念やと
なんとか言えばね 気楽なんですよ
その場合は その抵抗 抵抗力を排除しなくても良いことになるんですね
言い訳作っちゃうと 他人の原因にしちゃうと
まあ自分が別に何もしなくてもいいということで
結構気分が良くなります
しかし 自信がないのはそのまま
そのままなんですね 自信がないことはそのまま正当化するんだから
しかし 残念なことに ブッダの教えでは何でもかんでも自己責任にするんですね
そこはすごい大変なことで
もう自己責任にするんですね
それで 初期仏教の場合は
ブッダの教えの場合は
あの 直せなくてはならないということで
自信がない問題と それでまあ仏教から見れば
自信がないということは
他人のせいではなくて
親のしつけでもなくて
これ心理的な原因があるんですね
自信がないこと 活発になれないことは心の問題であることは明確です
いくつかの原因で心はスムーズに機能することはできなくなっているんです
原因はいくつかありまして
心が動かないんですね
そうすると体も動かないんですよ
しかし 現代使っている意味で
自信 あるいは英語で言えばセルフコンフィデンスですね
という用語はないんです
仏教では まあ自信というそれは使いますけど
自信という意味のパーリの単語はないんです
だから現代的な意味でね
昔の人間に自信は問題ではなかったでしょうね
まあ大体昔はなかったと思いますよ
そんなに社会がハチャメチャ発展して複雑になりまして
もう右も左もわからなくなって混乱状態になっている
現代は自信がない 自信がないと言うのであって
昔はすごいシンプルな社会ですから
何をするべきかということはもうほとんど決まってるし
仕事にしても 親が小さい時からもうね
仕事を教えてくれるし
そのまま親の仕事を続けることだから
何のことなく進んでいくんですよ
例えば 何か職業の家に生まれて
小さい時からそれ見ているんだから
お客さんにも顔を合わせているんだから
よく知っていることで
それでどんどん親が年取っていくと
息子が結構腕が上がっているし
一人前でしょうし それでそのまま仕事を続けるんですよ
自信がない どうしようとかね
競争しなくちゃいけないんだとかね
ライバル会社に乗っ取られないようにしなくちゃアカンとかね
そんな問題は何もないんですよ
畑仕事をする家であろうとも
まあ小さい時からもう畑で仕事をしているんだから
もう慣れたもんで だから別にこのシンプルな社会では
この自信という問題 は起こらないとは思います
この複雑すぎてどうすることもできない社会で
これ問題なんです 特に職業の場合は
現代は親の仕事をするということは決まってないでしょうに
自分が好きな職業を選べればいいんですね
そうすると 胸を張って自分の能力に合った仕事とかね
やりたい仕事とか なんとか探しちゃうでしょうね
そうなってくると 能力って何かと本人知らないんだからね
自分の能力は これいきなりぶつかっちゃいますね
壁には 自分に合った仕事を探してますと
仕事したことがない人はどうやって自分に合った仕事の概念生まれるんですかね
まだまだ若いんだから
だからもうはちゃめちゃですね
思考は それから親の仕事をするに決まってるんだったら大丈夫ですけど
現代そうでもないでしょうに
自分が教育で好きな仕事に行けばいいしね
そういうこと そういう社会だから
この自信がないという問題がもうじりじりと表れているんですよ
そこから原因の説明に行きます
これから一応現代人の問題を扱いますけど
これからはもう原因解明は昔も今もこれからも人類は同じです
だからブッダの普遍的な話にはなります
この時間のズレという現象があるんですね
このスクリーンがないと文字が見えないんだから
スクリーン入れたんで
ちょっと時間が で 人は今ここという具体的な生き方に慣れているならば
精神的な問題も失敗も起こりません
しかし 人間は具体的 現実的ではありません
現代人がすごく胸を張って
この具体性やら合理性やらいろんなことを喋ってますけど
昔の人々は神話を作ったり
おとぎ話を作ったり もう変だと
科学も発展してなかったんだからとかね
何でもかんでも迷信だらけではなかったとかね
悪口まで言うでしょうに
しかし 昔も今も 人間というのはまあ現実主義者じゃないんですよ
私の音聞こえないとどれぐらいボリュームを上げればいいかとかわからなくなっちゃうんで
自分では スピーカーどこにあるんですかね
え？じゃあ後ろだけ聞こえればいいでしょう
えっと この今ここというポイント
それは現実主義なんですよ
今ここです ここっていうのは空間的なところで
今っていうのは時間的なこと
だからこの時空関係で我々はいる場所もはっきり決まってるんですね
だから ある時空の時点で我々は何をするべきかということは
もうすぐもう定めてしまうんですよ
そこが時空関係変わるたびに変わっていくんですね
だから現実的になる 具体的になるということはそう簡単じゃないんですよ
なぜならば この時空関係で見ると
時間というのは常に流れていくんですね
それで場所も空間も常に変わっていくんですよ
この部屋にいるか 隣の部屋にいるかというね
あるいは玄関から玄関にいるか
玄関を出られる 出るか
それぞれによって時空関係変わるんですよ
だから時空関係変わるたびに
自分がやらなくちゃいけないことも
ずっとものすごい速いスピードで変わっていくんです
それをキャッチしていることが今ここという原理なんですよ
かなりレベル高い作業なんです
そこが答えなんです それができれば
ものすごい立派な人で
何の失敗もないで 人生は
ありえないんだからね
玄関の場合は その時間で
その空間でやるべきことをやればいいんだからね
そこで部屋に入っちゃうと
その時間で その空間でやるべきことをやればいいんです
会社に行ったら その時間で
その空間でやるべきことをやればいいんです
だから何か心の中で覚えておく
背負うものがなくなっちゃうんですよ
背負わないんです 何も
それで今忙しいんだから
それですごい精神的に楽になるし
何一つも失敗しない人間になるんですね
それが答えなんですけど
これが全然人間というのは理解しないんですよ
で 昔の人々はもう神話なんかね
もうもうあなた熱にかかっているのは
山に入るとか 神様にお礼をしなかったんだからとかね
そういう神秘的な解説したりしたんですけど
今の人間っていうのは
もう現代世界でいろんな時空関係連れて
いろんなことを考えたり妄想したりしているんです
時間をずらして物事を考えると
頭だけの一人相撲になるんですよ
時間ずらしちゃうと 単なる観念的な世界なんですよ
例えば今 3時であるとしましょう
時間は分かりませんだけど
まだ 3時になってないんですけど
で それで 5時のことを考えちゃうと
5時はもう存在しないでしょうに
あるいは今日の午前中の 8時半のことを考えると
もう観念的なんですね
存在しないんですよ だからそれは単なる自分の頭だけの相撲なんですね
で 心のエネルギーが浪費するので
やる気を出すこともできなくなる
それで頭をずっと使って回転させてるんだから
すごいエネルギーがなくなるんですよ
だから何かする力がないんですよ
もう疲れてるんです できる仕事でももうやる気がないんですよ
もう疲れて疲れてしまって
できないんです やってみても
だからこの時間のずれっていうのは大変なことで
これでもう自信がなくなりますよ
ですから もうさらに詳しく説明します
一つは未来にずれる まあ今もう 2時 47分なんですけど
今 2時 47分で何をするべきかではなくて
6時に何をするのか  8時に何をするのかとか
明日何しましょうかとかね
そういうことを頭の中でぐるぐる回転しちゃうと
これ未来にずれてしまいますね
それでエネルギーがなくなります
それで この未来にずれるという問題
未来にずれる人々は まず結果だけを妄想する
何かやるべき仕事があると
これはどんな結果になるんでしょうかとかね
いい結果出るんでしょうかとかね
まあ期待通りの結果にならなかったらどうしようかとかね
とにかく随分先の話を考えちゃうんですね
それが精神的な抵抗力になっちゃって動かなくなります
次にもう仮定について妄想する
これはどうすればいいでしょうかね
うまくいくでしょうか
とか 仮定について こうすればいいんじゃないか
ああすればいいんじゃないかとかね
それは明日やった方がいいんじゃないかとかね
もうあれこれと過程について妄想する
過程も将来なんで 今やってないんだからね
それから失敗を妄想する
それから成功を妄想する
成功したイメージをね
頭に入れちゃって妄想するんですよ
まだ仕事してないんですよ
だから失敗したイメージ入れるか成功したイメージ
どちらでもすごい危険なんですよ
例えば これからやろうとする仕事が失敗したことをシミュレーションしちゃうと
もう怖くなるんですよ
恥ずかしくておびえて
あるいは成功したイメージ
シミュレーションしちゃうと
えらく舞い上がったりして
大変なことになります
良い結果を出してから
何でしたっけ？喜ぶことも
喜ぶことじゃないんですね
怒ることか  怒ることでしょうかね
ちょっと打ち間違いで
なんか自分でわからなくなっちゃってる
いわゆる良い結果を出してからの状況
ああ 私はそれだったらこうなるんだ
ああなるんだとかね それで良い結果を出してから
自分がどれぐらい儲かるかと得するのかどうかね
そういうものも先に考えるんですよ
これも英語で言うわ 有名なデイドリミングというね
これあの まあちょっと子供たちにいろいろエピソードもありますけど
まあ日本語ではどうか分かりませんだけど
まあ自分の国ではなんかこの小さなエピソードがありまして
まあすごい貧しい女の子がまああると思いますけど
日本でもね  日本では取らぬ狸の皮算用というのは
それを聞いたことはない
で あのちっちゃな女の子がまず女の子がいて
この山羊一頭いるんですね
家で それでもう仕事しなくちゃいけない
小さいですけども 貧乏だから
それでお父さんがもうなんとかもうもう山羊から乳を絞って
まあ娘さんにこれ売ってこいと
彼女は行きたくないんですね
あまりもう服もボロボロで着てないし
で 街に行きたくないんですね
それで街に行く間に妄想するんですよ
私はこの山羊の乳を売って
金たくさんもらいまして
そのお金でこの金を貯めて
今ヤギ一頭ですけどね
もう一頭買っちゃいますよ
それでもっと牛乳 牛乳じゃなくて乳を売れますよ
でもう一頭買えますと
そこでヤギっていうのはすぐ子供いっぱい産むんだから
これでどんどん繁殖するんだと
そうなってくると もう思い存分
もういろいろ売れて金儲かりますと
それからもうヤギよりは牛の方が儲かりますからね
牛を買っちゃいますよと
で 牛もどんどん増やして
それから金持ちになって
もう土地も買って家も作ってとか
どんどんどんどん妄想するんですね
それで自分がね こんなボロ服じゃなくて
すごいかっこいい美しい服を着て
お化粧して あの耳に耳はやらね
首はやらね 腕はやらね
いっぱいつけてかっこよくするんだと
そうするともう結構男たちがね
私の方からいろいろ見るでしょうと
見たっても私はね あの連中には全然もうもうダメやつなんだよと言って
もう首を振っちゃったんですね
首を振ってたら 頭の上にあったあの山羊の
乳入れた器が落ちて壊れてしまったんです
それで夢が全部そこで終わり
まだ町まで行ってないんです
で 同じ似ているエピソードはね
あんまり派手に妄想することはとても危険なことというのは
坊さん 仏教のエピソードの一つあります
あまり今日のテーマに関係ないんですけど
まあ一応将来は妄想すると恥かけるということである
あの方がお釈迦様のところに出家したんです
で 出家して まあ年を取っていた方で
すごい真面目に瞑想して悟り開くんですよ
それで自分がこんな偉大な老師をね
もう親戚にも教えてなくちゃいけないということで
妹の息子がいたんですね
どうしても妹の息子だから
まあもう可愛いし で 君も出家したらどうですか？と
いうと この人もやっぱりおじさんの方がすごくもう大事にしていたんだから
おじさん言うならば出家しますよと
ことで おじさんのとこ出家するんですね
二人がもうすごく仲良く修行したりはする
それでこの若者が別なところで行に入って
行が終わったら信者さんが生地一つくれたんですね
これも作ってくださいと
生地というのはすごい当時でね
かなり高価なものですからね
そこですごい高価なもう値段のある生地をもらったところで
この人が あ これはおじいさんのお坊様に上げなくちゃいけないんだと
私の面倒をよく見てくれるんだと
よく仏教を教えてくれるんだ
だからこれは私が使ったらとんでもないんだ
もう長老に師匠にお布施しますということで
すごく胸を張って持ってきたんですね
持ってきて 自分の師匠に礼をして
これはいただいたもので
先生にお布施しますと
というと この方は阿羅漢だから
もう余分なものは取ろうとはしない
まあ自分にはこれも一着ある
どう見てもこの若者にはもうない
新しいものはね だからいい
結構です いりませんと言ったんですね
親戚同士だから別に まあいいや
いらんいらんと言ったでしょうね
おそらく 親戚同士でなかったら
まあもしかすると まあまあ
こういうこういうわけで
必要ではありませんというふうに言ったかもしれませんし
で 断られたことで この若者はちょっと傷ついちゃったんですね
すごくもう夢一杯で 師匠にね
もう差し上げようと持ってきたものだから
まあそれで まあそれでもおじい様だからね
あの団扇で空気を送ってやったんですね
師匠はどこかに座っていて
そうしながら まあ私はおじいさんに嫌われてるんだと
おじいさんに 昔みたいな私のことは可愛いと今は思わないみたいだと
おじさんが私のことを可愛いと思ってもらわないとね
出家したって面白くも何でもないんだと
ちっちゃい時からおじいさんが一生懸命可愛がってくれたんだから
この人は飛んで行った
出家したんですよ 面白くも何でもないんだと
じゃあ還俗するってやるとしてやるそうと
還俗したらもうもう仕事もないし
でもこの生地もありますからね
これは結構なお金で売れるし
それで農業できるんじゃないかと
それで私は農業とかなんとかして
しっかり頑張るんだと
しっかり頑張っちゃって
いくらか金も貯まって
お嫁さんももらえますと
で もうイメージをするんで
シミュレーションのね
それでお嫁さんもらって
子供を産まれるとたん
もうその世界に入り込んじゃうんですね
もう赤ちゃんがいるっていうこと
赤ちゃんがいると やっぱり長老に見せて祝福してもらわなくちゃと
自分の子供 それでもう頭の中でドラマが働くでしょうに
それでまあ奥さんも赤ちゃんも車に乗せて
牛車に乗せて まあお寺に来ると
それで道路っていうのはでこぼこだからね
それで自分が一応車を運転しなくちゃいけないんでしょうし
そこで女の人っていうのは体も弱いし
もしかするとこのでこぼこの道路でね
車が片ちょこっと傾いたところで
家内はもしかすると赤ちゃんを落とすかもしれませんと
赤ちゃん落としちゃうと
これ大変だからね そうするともうこら
お前何やってるんだ しっかり赤ちゃん抱いて
なんで行かないのかと言って怒るんですね
怒っても殴っちゃうんですね
奥さんを殴っちゃったんだけど
自分持ってる団扇ね あの長老の頭殴ったんですよ
で 長老は何ももう振り返してみることもなく
もう自分の家内殴るのはいいんだけど
なんで俺を私を殴るんでしょうかと
聞いたんですね 長老は自分がもう悟っている方だから
このドラマをじーっとチェックしているんです
相手の心の中で起こる
だから私ももう家内殴ってるんで
私を殴るなよということを言ったんだから
全部バレてるとわかっちゃって
そこで逃げたみたいですけどね
だから仏教の世界でこの時間ずれることはとっても危険で恥ずかしいですよ
何もしてないのに ほんのちょっとの時間で
ほんのちょっとの時間があればかなりずれるんですよ
あの方にしたって何年もずれちゃったんだからね
これはまあ将来に対する問題なんですね
それで 現代の我々はそういう妄想も結構するし
まだ仕事もやってないのに
仕事を大成功して大金持ちになることをイメージする
何もできなくなっちゃうんです
それから過去にずれる
これも大きな問題 過去のことばっかり考えていること
過去の失敗を妄想する
過去で同じことをやってこうなったか
あなた失敗ことを妄想しちゃうと
もう自信がなくなるでしょうし
失敗 失敗した時の気持ちを妄想する
そうすると その嫌な気分がどんどん再現するでしょうに
成功したことがあっても
周りの反応が良くなったこと
期待通りになかったことを妄想する
例えば過去で仕事して成功したんだけど
あんまり周りに受けなかったとかね
みんなそうかっていうことで終わっちゃうと
もう気持ち悪いんですね
あるいは自分が思った通りの
まあすごくうまくいくと思ったんですけど
まあそれほどなかったと
そういうことを考えたりする
あるいは新しい仕事をしようとしちゃうと
自分には経験がないんだと
やったことがないんだと
と思ったりする それも過去のことなんですよ
経験があるって そんな風に妄想して時間のズレを起こしちゃう
それどちらでも自信がなくなる原因になります
それで この何かをする場合は
過去の経験というのは必要ですよ
将来に対して具体的な計画を立てることも必要なんです
また どのように仕事をこなすかはシミュレーションしてみることも必要です
仕事があります これはどういう風にしましょうかといって
このちょっと過程をちょっとシミュレーションすることも必要なんですよ
これ 時間を忘れてはならないということなんですね
しかし これらはすべて具体的で合理的な思考です
それはすごく具体的で合理的に
過去にはこういうこういう経験がありますから
まあそこそこできるでしょうとかね
あるいはまあ こういうこういう計画で
こういうこういう目的でやるぞとかね
それならこんな順番でやらなくちゃいけないんだとか
そういう設計図っていうのは必要なんですけど
それはすごい具体的に合理的にならなくちゃいかないんですね
自信がない人の場合は
具体性も合理性もありません
ただの妄想 ただの時間のずれ
この具体性 合理性がないことが問題なんです
ちょこちょこっと過去のことを考えたとしても
ちょこちょこっと将来のことを考えたっても
具体性を忘れないならば問題はないんですよ
それから現在 例えば過去に将来にずれなくても
現在でも我々はいろんなトラブルを起こすんですね
過去将来の妄想をしなくても
自信がない人に 現在という時間にずれても問題があるんです
具体的に仕事をどうすれば良いのかを見ない
漠然ととして見るので何もわからない
何かやろうと思っちゃうと
これはどういう仕事か
私は何をやるべきかということじゃなくて
これやるのかといきなりものすごく漠然として見ちゃうんですよ
そうするとわからなくなっちゃうんですよ
どこから手を出せば良いか
どこから始めれば良いかはわからなくなるので
自信が失ってしまいますよ
あまりも自分のやるべきことを何でもかんでも漠然として見ちゃうと
もうどこから始めればいいか
どんな風にやればいいか
どこから手を出せばいいかとわからなくなるんですよ
あまり将来のことを考えてないんですよ
過去のことも考えてないんだけど
現代のこのアプローチがあまりにも良くないんですね
鋭くないんですよ それでも自信がなくなるんです
一応いくらかポイント変わるみたいです